hello John Perry here welcome to my
second ever podcast II interview type
video that's currently what I'm calling
these I should probably come up with a
better name but I guess that's good
enough for now
today my guest is Perry Marshall who
just happens to be my arch-nemesis that
might be a little bit of an exaggeration
but Perry Marshall and I certainly have
clashed in the past Perry Marshall is an
engineer and a businessman a few years
back he decided to take his engineering
expertise and use it to interpret
evolutionary biology he wrote a book
about it called evolution 2.0 which
actually has some pretty interesting
parts in it but sadly it's peppered with
what I would call a creationist
flavourings he is certainly not a
creationist in the traditional sense and
he's definitely not a Ken Ham type
you'll hear right away when you hear him
talk he's a very brilliant guy but his
books creationist overtones caused him
and I to fight a little bit on the
Internet we got to do some Twitter Wars
and so on today however we will not be
fighting each other we are putting aside
our differences for the moment to team
up to fight our common enemy think of it
as you know Thor and Loki joining forces
to fight Thanos but hopefully our story
will end a little nicer so who is our
common enemy our common enemy is really
everyone that doesn't understand what
the term information means but still
insists on using their misguided
concepts of information to argue either
for or against evolution I am talking
about the ridiculous arguments made by
creationists such as mutations can never
produce new information or the equally
ignorant arguments sometimes made by
atheists such as the genetic code isn't
really a code it's just sort of like a
code both of those arguments are
completely unfounded and today Perry
Marshall and I will explain why so
without further ado here is my
conversation with Perry Marshall about
genetic information one more thing
before I get started I would just like
to apologize for the fact that my last
name is his first name that is a little
bit confusing if you happen to be just
meeting the two of us he
on this podcast but we were born that
way so deal with it my guest today is
Perry Marshall he is an engineer and an
author how long ago did we meet Perry
probably two or three years ago you
published your book in 2015 it was right
around the beginning of the book coming
out somewhere in it or so yeah two and a
half years let's say Perry Marshall
wrote a book called evolution 2.0 and I
believe it was the way I was introduced
to you is your secretary sent me a copy
of the book in digital form asking me to
review it and I did and I reviewed it
negatively weight Perry Perry and I
disagree on a lot of things and today
we're going to talk about things we
don't disagree on we're gonna be talking
about genetics and the genetic code what
the heck the genetic code is and you
might be wondering why I'm not asking a
biologist about this or geneticist about
this I've actually found you know Perry
Marshall I started off kind of I guess
in a Twitter fight right gun back and
forth but we ended up taking it to you
know e-mails back and forth and then
phone conversations and we've we become
friends over the course of these these
arguments we've had I've come to realize
that Perry is probably the the best at
describing from an engineer's
perspective what the genetic code is
he's he's really been able to simplify
for me in our conversations what is a
coding language and why is it that the
genetic code matches coding languages
perfectly when we say that the genetic
code is a code that's not an analogy but
the genetic code really is a code and
geneticists understand this Watson and
Crick understood this but a lot of
people don't understand this today and
I've I've found that the way that Perry
is able to articulate this is probably
the best that I've seen so even though
we do disagree on many things we
definitely agree on this and I'm really
happy to have you here well thanks for
having me and I one of the things I like
about what you're doing is is if
somebody brings a useful view then let's
have the conversation and it's not all
this territorial stuff which is all too
common in
in the evolution conversation so yeah
let's let's mix it up let's let's talk
about this because this is a super
central issue to the whole eye not only
to evolution but also an origin of life
I think also to artificial intelligence
and so yeah there's a lot - yeah - dig
in no at this point our viewers are
probably just itching to know what it is
that you and I argue about so maybe we
should give them a little tease about
that before moving on there were a lot
of good parts in your book which is why
I gave it 2 out of 5 stars
but I doct you three stars because of
the books main argument essentially you
say that the genetic code really is a
code and by the way I totally agree with
you on that but then you go on to claim
that only intelligent minds can invent
codes and I certainly do not agree with
you on that
from there you conclude that the genetic
code must have been invented by an
intelligent mind now I know that that is
an oversimplification of your argument
but is that a fair oversimplification of
your argument oh it's fair it's it is a
little oversimplified because I am I'm
completely open to a chemical or
algorithmic or a physical law that
explains where codes come from and so
far nobody's figured that out and and so
this is why we have a five million
dollar technology prize and I don't I'm
not sure that was really where the
disagreement was I think it was probably
more like you you're a lot more
confident in the current like the RNA
world hypothesis and stuff like that
where I think the answer is probably
going to come from a completely
different direction if this is able to
be solved so probably most of our
disagreements have actually been more
along the lines of what can replicate or
do and stuff like that but I one thing
that's for sure is we I think we have a
pretty similar understanding of what
codes and coding systems are that the
information problem in biology hasn't
really been solved for
of life in this worthwhile problem I'm
pretty sure we agree about that yes yeah
yeah we do let's talk about it what is
information because this is this is the
part way I really really appreciate your
work is being able to really clearly
define what information is and you know
I sent you this email with kind of the
four different types of information that
people typically talk about one of the
one of the problems with this discussion
of information is that people are
usually talking about different things
so they talk past each other yeah and so
I've got these four types of it of
information there's physical information
there's coded information there's
epigenetics these types of information
we find in life there's epigenetics and
then there is information transferred
between organisms through different
signals to restate exactly what you said
using slightly different words there's
there's physical properties there's code
there's intracellular and there's
intercellular information is that a fair
yeah yeah right
so there's physical information like how
big is the rock how heavy is the rock
how much inertia does the rock have what
color is it you know like all these
kinds of things and these things are
certainly information in the common
vernacular they are not coded
information in the specific engineering
sense okay when I have a like a rock
right over here so you know it's dark
gray and it's got these minerals in and
it's got a certain weight and all this
kind of stuff and so those those are all
properties but the the rock does not
contain any language with respect to
itself right the only information
transfer you can have between with
physical information is when they
connect so you know if you get hit by a
bus information about its mass and
density is going to be transferred into
your body and I guess someone who's
really good at reading that could figure
out what hits you right you know we
do this with we look at craters that we
can tell how big the space rock was that
caused them so physical information is
transferred when things connect or you
know the light can be admitted off of a
physical object and then hit our eye and
that's physical information and that's
that's what physicists study it's not
super important for when we're talking
about the genetic code that's right a
different type of information coded
information that's right so then you
have code and so I'm gonna define code
as let's say symbols symbols passed from
an encoder to a decoder all right and so
this gets to Claude Shannon's
information model where you have an
encoder you have a message and you have
a decoder and the information goes from
here to here and this is me and you
sending text messages this is me and you
sending emails
this is ASCII this is HTML
it could be barcode zip code English
Chinese anything like that really you
you have layers of information because
something is coming in here into the
encoder and this being translated to
something and then it's been being
decoded and then it's coming out and
then there is a correspondence where
what comes out has a proper relationship
between what came in and you can
determine whether an error has occurred
or not right so it's your daughter
watching her iPad you know and through
the Wi-Fi or you're driving in the car
and you know if the cell signal drops
you know it's because some error
happened it couldn't recover from it and
so an intrinsic idea of symbolic
information is that a translation has
occurred and the transmission has
occurred and you can determine whether
it happened correctly or not and this is
the basis of all did
communication for people hearing this
for the first time it might be really
really abstract and really weird the
purpose of coding information is to
transmit it somewhere so it can be
decoded later
and so when I'm speaking I have an idea
in my head and I say Perry want to do a
podcast later what I'm doing is I'm
converting this idea in my head to
vibrations of my mouth which go through
the air and I mean in this case they're
also going through wires and stuff but
forget all that going through the air to
your ear and your ear is set up already
to take that those vibrations and your
brain is set up already to understand
what those vibrations mean and so the
encoder and the decoder have to be set
up in advance to understand what the
message is an order for communication to
happen there must be a language or a
code that both the encoder and the
decoder agree upon you could say in your
book you use the example of a keyboard
when you press the letter A the letter A
gets converted by your keyboard into
zeros and ones transmitted through a
wire to the computer the computer takes
that and turns that into an A on your
computer screen so you've got an encoder
the encoder would be the keyboard right
and the language here would be zeros and
ones binary code yes how to read B that
computer screen computer itself yeah
exactly right and say you press you
press a on your keyboard write an A one
zero zero zero zero zero one goes
through a wire because that's the ASCII
symbol for a and then yes an a you know
little pixels that look like an a appear
on your screen and you go okay so I
press the letter A and an A appeared so
as encoded and decoded correctly that's
a I mean that is as simple as that is
that is like if you can understand that
then you you understand the the
foundation of all digital communication
because that is how it works right right
right
that's also how verbal communication
works but you know we're using sequences
of words or sound vibrations instead of
sequences of zeros
but the principles here are exactly the
same now just a quick note to our
viewers hopefully Perry and I have done
a good job explaining what coded
information is but in case it's still a
little bit confusing I have a diagram
here that I'm showing on screen that
will hopefully clarify everything for
you so take a close look if you need it
on the top row we see a simple concept
of a communication system a
communication system consists of an
encoder a message that can be
transmitted a decoder that receives the
transmission and decodes it in the
second row I have a real-life example a
keyboard is an encoder when the letter a
is pressed it's encoded into a message
of zeros and ones transmitted through a
wire to a computer where it's decoded
back into the letter A which is then
displayed on the screen true
communication only happens when a
language is set up ahead of time a
language that both the encoder and the
decoder quote know in this case that
language is binary code in Row three I
have a human example we have a person as
the encoder he wants a house he encodes
his desired house into a message in this
case a blueprint the blueprint allows
him to transmit that message to a
decoder in this case a contractor the
contractor decodes that message into a
house what I'm going to do now is show
you a five-minute animation about how
DNA works and it's a video that I made
for my other channel stated clearly if
you're listening to this as a podcast
instead of watching it as a video that's
probably okay but actually watching at
least this part for the next five
minutes would be ideal either way though
as the animation plays out see if you
can figure out which part of the genetic
system acts as the encoder which part is
the message which part is the decoder
and which part is the decoded message
just hit play here stated clearly
presents what is Dan
and how does it work DNA also known as
deoxyribonucleic acid is a molecule it's
a bunch of atoms stuck together in the
case of DNA these atoms combine to form
the shape of a long spiraling ladder
sort of like this one here if you ever
studied biology or saw the movie
Jurassic Park you probably heard that
DNA acts as a blueprint or a recipe for
a living thing but how how on earth can
a mere molecule act as a blueprint for
something as complex and wonderful as a
tree a dog to help answer that question
let's first take a quick look at amino
acids amino acids are tiny little
chemicals inside our bodies that are so
important they're often referred to as
the building blocks of life there's
about 20 different kinds each with their
own unique shape the neat thing about
them is they can be attached to each
other kind of like Legos to produce an
endless variety of larger particles
known as proteins amino acids make up
proteins proteins along with other
chemicals combine to form living cells
cells make up tissues tissues make up
organs and organs when they're all put
together and functioning of course
combine to form living creatures like
you and me these proteins that make up
our bodies and keep in mind there's
millions of different kinds of proteins
they each have to be formed in the
perfect shape in order to function if
they're the wrong shape they usually
won't work
that's where DNA comes in DNA does a lot
of interesting things some of which you
don't fully understand but one of its
main and most well understood functions
is to tell amino acids how to line up
and form themselves into the perfect
protein shapes in theory if the right
proteins are built at the right time and
in the right place everything else from
cells to organs to entire creatures will
come out just fine
this here is a simplified model of DNA
it shows us that the steps of the ladder
are made up of four different kinds of
chemicals shown here by different colors
and letters if you look at just one half
of a molecule you can read its chemical
sequence or genetic code from top to
bottom sort of like a book a single
strand of DNA is extremely long millions
of letters long it spends most of it's
life coiled up like a noodle living
inside the nucleus or the centerpiece of
a cell I mean all assets however live
outside the nucleus in what's called the
cytoplasm to help DNA interact with the
cytoplasm and convert those amino acids
into proteins special chemicals inside
the nucleus make partial copies of the
DNA code these partial copies called RNA
look a lot like DNA but they're shorter
of course and they're missing one of
their sides they're small shape and size
allows them to fit through tiny pores in
the nucleus out to the cytoplasm and
into the mouths of another particle
called a ribosome ribosomes are protein
building machines they read the RNA code
three letters at a time suck amino acids
out of their surroundings and stick them
together in a chain according to the RNA
code as the chain grows it bends it
folds and it sticks to itself to form a
perfectly shaped protein every three
letters of the RNA code tell the
ribosome which of the 20 different kinds
of amino acids should be added next for
example
CAA tells the ribosome to grab a
glutamine a GU tells it to grab a serine
and so on once a protein is built it can
then go on to do a number of different
things one of which could be to help
form a brand new cell so to answer the
original question what is DNA DNA is a
molecular blueprint for a living thing
how does it work DNA creates RNA RNA
creates protein proteins go on to form
life listen
haier process as complicated as
sophisticated as magical as it might
seem is entirely based in chemistry it
can be studied it can be understood I'm
John Perry and that's DNA stated clearly
ok that was the animation now hopefully
it was clear to everyone that the DNA or
I suppose you could say the entire
nucleus could be thought of as the
encoder the RNA is the message which is
transmitted out to the ribosome the
ribosome is the decoder and the decoded
message is a protein throughout this
process the genetic code is the language
that the message was written in any
mutation in the DNA would modify the
message that is transcribed into RNA and
would then modify the type of protein
that is built that's right that's right
so you have you have a strand of DNA and
then we're going to messenger RNA and
then we're trans so that's transcribing
into message messenger RNA and then
we're translating to amino acids which
are strung together to make proteins and
so this is a decoder sorry this is an
encoder I'm very sorry this is an
encoder and the ribosome over here is a
decoder and it's it's highly analogous
to this so a is 1 0 0 1 and B is 1 0 0 0
1 0 and you can make a whole table in
the ASCII code of what that is and here
GGG makes glycine and AAA make slicing
and there's there's another table for
this too and so like these are both
physical processes I mean in a computer
processor there are there are electric
fields or electromagnetic switches or
transistors switching off and they are
so there is a physical process going
here and there is a physical process
going here there
both physical processes but it's very
significant that we at we understand as
abstractly and symbolically being a code
and the reason in genetics we sit the
reason it's a code and it's not just
materials as AAA is not lysine and GGG
is not glycine in fact the AAA never
makes it into the string of amino acids
it's just it's just a set of
instructions right and of course we know
in genetics that if you if you swap one
set of DNA for another and you replace
it with some other code then it'll just
run a different set of instructions in
it it doesn't care where the molecules
came from as long as they're there and
they're the right order it's gonna
happen and so genetic code is just as
much a code as anything that happens in
your computer or a barcode or zip code
or anything something to really drive
home here is there's nothing spooky
about there's no ghost in the machine
like you said everything is a physical
process this is true in your computer
this is true in the genome what's
happened here is that there is a set of
rules that have been set up in advance
so that the communication system works
if you don't have those rules set up in
advance the communication systems not
going to work that's what's giving this
kind of illusion of this spooky ghost in
the machine it's it's it's these rules
that exist and that's that's what's
making the genetic code a legitimate
code it has rules we've actually been a
little figure out what those rules are
you can look at them they're in a chart
we can hack cells by inserting different
messages in the genome and those cells
will make the proteins that we want them
to make that we told we tell them to
make this is this is definitely a code
well you know I'll just address I've had
a lot a lot of people kind of push and
push back on this I'll just add a little
layer of detail so in engineering
there's this thing called the OSI 7
layer model and it's the idea of codes
within codes within codes and this
actually goes to where we're going to go
next
very nicely and so so in the seven layer
model it's it's kind of like it's kind
of like this and seven is kind of an
arbitrary number there could be ten or
twenty but-but-but-but layer layer zero
is the physical substance okay and in
this case it's the actual DNA strand
it's the fact that the and bases are
what they are
okay is that going well through the DNA
strand and the ribosome no no this is
just the code itself we're not okay not
really thinking about the machinery
we're only looking at the code okay okay
so and in a computer it's the Ethernet
cable it's a wire it's a copper wire or
it's fiber optic where it's Wi-Fi okay
so you write physical layer okay layer
one engine in computers is 1 or 0 so is
there a pulse of light or not a pulse of
light on the fiber-optic cable or is
there 5 volts or zero volts on the wire
okay so in electricity its bolts okay
and in in genetics
it's the ACGT okay so it's a it's a one
or a zero so in other words this is at
the level where computers are binary and
biology is quaternary right because
because biology has four symbols right
and then level two is where we're
grouping these in groups of three for
coding genetics so this is the this is
the basis and this is the codons okay so
so the basic genetic code stuff that
everybody's heard about is these three
layers the layer zero one and two is
what engineers would say okay over on
the on the engineering side it would be
like a ski
we're like you know how this doesn't
happen anymore if you used to pay stuff
for Microsoft Word into an email and it
would give you all this garbage oh yeah
yeah okay remember it was because this
level that your email program didn't
have the right stuff to deal with this
level and then you'd have these garbage
characters right well so then like
there's three four or five in
engineering like the five six seven and
number seven would be like Microsoft
Word okay okay and and so if if I send
you an email I'm typing stuff up here
and a message gets wrapped in a message
and a message and a message and a
message and a message and a message and
a message and then it goes through a
wire and it comes into your computer and
then you decode it the exact opposite
direction this is one of the most
important concepts in in computers and
the same thing roughly is going on in
higher levels of so when you get when
you jump from codons to proteins
you're now you just went from here to
here okay or when you have a whole bunch
of proteins and then you eventually
you're at a chromosome like now you're
like way up here somewhere and so
there's layers of information in all of
these systems there's a tremendous
similarity that yeah that concept the
once you get above the code on that
concept gets fuzzy for me so are you
thinking of Microsoft words at the top
of your pyramid here would that be like
an organism yeah that'd be a so yeah
okay oh yeah like this would be a whole
cell right and of course there might not
there might be 30 layers not seven but
right right right but at some level you
have the whole entire organism and then
you have these sub parts so it's it's
also like language like we have we have
physical piece of paper and then we have
letters and then we have word
then we have grammar yeah and you know
and so people deal with this stuff every
day they just don't so we could say well
okay this is you know this is the deeper
this is like this is the symbolism of
Shakespeare or something like that right
and and you know and these are the
phrases that he used and these are the
rules of grammar so people actually deal
with this all the time they just don't
usually think of it they don't usually
break it up into these components all
right so I did some work with Stuart
West on major evolutionary transitions
which is video I know you've seen and it
seems to me and looking at your chart
here that this you could map each one of
those trends those transitions on top of
here so he goes from you know he sees it
from from genes to cells to multi-celled
organisms and then to like bees and
stuff have an extra layer where they're
the actual entire hive acts as a single
organism so I guess I guess if we were
to map those on here there would be yeah
there be I think that would bring us to
six or so if you if you're looking at
bees yeah there'd be a lot of those in
fact we could even we can go to the
whole planet and we could be in the Gaia
hypothesis and yeah you know we'd be
like way up in the stratosphere
somewhere right right this is a very
useful way to look at stuff but because
there there is a hierarchy to it how are
you relating that to the other types of
communication that we're the other types
of information we're talking about
earlier okay so there's there's an
intracellular there's communication
inside the cell and then there's
communication outside the cell so so
inside the cell
one thing that organisms do is they'll
go read a section of DNA
they'll transcribe something into RNA
and something will happen and this isn't
only in reproduction this will this
could happen other events that are going
on in the cell in fact as I understand
it the cell is sort of accessing the
hard drive all the time
for different reasons right it's like
your computer does right like you go to
a program you didn't use for two days
and then all of a sudden the computer is
like wait a second you know and then
it's got to wake up and the hard drives
start spinning and then all of a sudden
that program works well same thing
happens there so what that means is that
somewhere in these middle layers
something is being accessed it's sort of
like hey we need that paragraph would
you go get that paragraph and bring it
over here because there's something we
need to do right we need it we need to
digest this food or or something like
that right let me let me clarify a
couple things for people that might be
getting lost here when we're talking
about genetics so your genome is it's
organized into chromosomes but we can
actually kind of ignore that for this
conversation just as if you think of
your genome was just one super long
strand of DNA all along that strand of
DNA there are certain chunks that are
between a couple thousand letters long
to a couple million letters long that we
call genes and those those genes are
things that get turned into RNA and read
but read by a ribosome to make a protein
I mean you've got thousands of them
there's over 20,000 different genes in
your genome but they they're not just
all constantly being read all constantly
being used most of them are actually
turned off most of the time we say
they're being used when they're
transcribed into RNA that RNA is then
read by the ribosome and it builds a
protein and of course this is a huge
oversimplification of things but what
you're saying is that this extra level
of information above the codon is the
information about when things should be
turned on and when things should be
turned off right and it could be it
could be things like at six weeks of the
development of the embryo this thing
should start happening there's just all
kinds of things like that
epigenetics is this field that describes
a lot of these different processes and
we just call all of them epigenetics but
there's a lot of different ones and they
you know
people studying at the genetics know
that and they're studying them
individually but a lot of times when
people are trying to learn about
epigenetics it's really confusing
because you think it's one process but
it's actually dozens maybe even hundreds
of processes that we barely are
beginning to understand another thing to
point out too is every single cell of
you in your body has the same genome and
my eyeball cells and my tongue cells
exact same genome but different genes
are turned off and different genes are
turned on and that's why the cells
create completely different proteins and
behave completely differently so this
epigenetic layer of information is
extremely important and it's highly
highly developed in multi-celled
organisms like ourselves it's less
developed in simpler multi-celled
organisms like sponges but it's
everywhere epigenetics is found in
pretty much every cell that seems to be
operating roughly in these levels here
it's kind of in the middle levels of
information
it's like graying out software menus
like like you've download the trial
software and there's all these things
that you can't do and then you pay the
money and you paste it in the code and
then all of a sudden okay this turn now
you can print and now you you know you
do all these things right and so so
epigenetics is like the code is all
there but you just shut off certain
things so if if I start playing guitar
and develop calluses epigenetic switches
will go hey hang on to those dead skin
cells longer because those calluses are
useful and you know it's not entirely
clear but it looks as though
in extreme cases that change could be
passed on to children what is the
capacity for these temporary epigenetic
changes to eventually become hard coded
in the genome but it seems sensible to
propose that they probably eventually
can be my perception of of the
epigenetics aspect of evolution is it
means that that real-time adaptation is
happening 24/7 365 everywhere in the
world with pretty much every organism
this is why organisms are so finely
tuned to their environment because these
feet
back loops are constantly okay adjust
adjust adjust adjust this would be a
Lamarckian type evolution where
experiences that you encounter modify
and up modifying the phenotype of your
children and we do know that it can
happen but we're not we're not sure if
epigenetic traits can ever actually
cause a lasting evolutionary change and
if if so we don't we haven't honed down
the mechanism yet so it's it's still
unclear yeah and this question is like
right at the bleeding edge of biology
right now like I'm sure twenty years
from now we'll have a bunch of
definitive answers about this but right
now this is literally where the edges I
mean if a grad student want to go chase
something down this would be a great
subject to chase down because I don't
even get the impression that there's
enough people working on this I mean I a
year to go I was emailing a bunch of
people like you know guys that write 200
page epigenetics text books and and
they're like yeah we don't really know
so it's it's it's fascinating if I was
to cast my vote I would vote for we're
gonna find a way that these changes
become permanent it certainly would be
advantageous the two camps here would be
that epigenetic changes that are passed
on to children are simply an adaptation
so that that child will be more in tuned
to the parents phenotype but it's a
temporary adaptation and so that's
that'd be one camp and the other camp is
that this is actually a mechanism for
lasting evolution and so those those are
both it kind of seems right now that but
it could go either way I agree so now
let's talk about intercellular or even
inter inter organism communication and
information that exists in biology so
it's it's still code one of my favorite
TED Talks is by Barney Basler and it's
called how bacteria talk and she
explains how bacteria have signals and
they'll send these little molecules in
the shape of the molecules is it's very
much like like letters in in words you
know I mean it
the analogy is unmistakable and it's
like they have words like me and you and
us and them is is there enough of us and
okay like you know John went out in the
cold last night and there's a whole
bunch of us let's attack and then John
wakes up with a you know with a sinus
infection or something two o'clock in
the morning and and this is because the
bacteria are communicating with each
other and this this raises eight there's
a whole field called semiotics and
semiotic is like linguistic basically
and it's a lens that looks through
biology as linguistic exchanges between
as communication events okay
can you spell that out a semiotic sem
iot i see okay it's related to semiosis
which is a while i don't know the root
words mean it's basically linguistics is
what it is and there's whole journals of
biosemiotics that you could go find it's
a it's a hot topic stewart west is he's
written a textbook called behavioral
ecology he worked on it he was one of
the authors of it and in that he he I
outlines signaling theory he talked
about how these different signals evolve
so we've got we have very distinctive
signals that that these cells are using
for a lot of people talking about
molecules in bacteria might be a little
bit abstract if we can actually pull out
and look at animals because different
animals will develop languages between
each other and you know we're a lot more
used to thinking of gestures and words
as languages versus molecules it's
really the same thing it shouldn't
confuse people but but when you think of
molecules you think it gets weird it's
not very relatable so when you're
running in a herd that the point of
being in a herd is you know if there's a
predator outside of the herd you can
actually hide inside the herd to not get
eaten so everybody's kind of being a
coward and trying to get into the middle
of the herd where it's safe
and the entire herd when there's a
full-on attack of a pride of lions is
attacking you heard the entire herd will
start running and your chances of
getting into the herd safely are pretty
high they're higher than trying to run
off on your own but running in a herd is
slower than running on your own so
there's this there's this problem here
and so the Lions can easily catch up to
the herd it's no problem all the animals
in her kind of tripping over each other
a little bit and you know they just run
slower than they would it just one lion
versus one gazelle right
and so the gazelles on the outside just
panicked wanting to get it to the inside
and when the lion comes near because
they can't run forward full speed they
will jump vertically upward as high as
they can and what we found is that lions
can read this they're reading this as a
signal that gazelle jumped super high if
I single him out I'm screwed he's gonna
run away from me he's way too strong but
if they see another one jump and it
can't jump very high they know that's
the one I should go for and so this is a
this is a behavior that started out as a
panicky behavior from these these
antelope or from these gazelles in this
case and has become it's it's start it's
become a cue for the lion the Lions
using his brain he figures out okay if I
go after the the one that jumps high I'm
screwed if I go for the one that can't
jump very good I'm probably gonna win
and once predators begin to realize this
there was now a selective pressure for
jumping super high for gazelles and
there's actually when we study their
body when we say their Anatomy they've
actually hurt their ability to run fast
because their mechanics have evolved to
jump higher than they showed normally so
there's been a compromise and evolution
has actually pulled them towards jumping
abnormally high simply because it scares
Lions it intimidates these Lions this is
an example of aq turning into a signal
so you have what started out as a cue
the line picked up on this oh that one's
healthy don't eat that one and then
natural selection picked up on this for
the gazelle if you want to if you want
to show the lion how he'll
who you are you better jump high and so
then evolution started pulling them
towards high jump
according to signaling theory once
natural selection starts favoring the Q
sender to give a stronger Q that is
officially called a signal that's it's a
little fuzzy when that exactly starts
because when something first starts to
evolve it's horrible and it it's refined
over time this is how he proposes that
languages evolved between bacteria and
so on so all bacteria are excreting
waste products and so if there's a lot
of waste products around you you know
there's a lot of bacteria around you and
if it's a lot of the same species it's
gonna be the same waste products and so
you can tell if there's a lot of your
kin in your neighborhood that could
trigger something to oh I should start
excreting digestive enzymes because
we'll probably be able to all work in
harmony to digest this big piece of food
in front of us so that's that's how he
sees the evolution of signaling
happening in biology today these really
and they get really complicated I mean
if you look at how a flower communicates
with a bee it can get really complicated
and then look at how bees communicate
with other bees through these dances and
look at how humans communicate through
verbal language it gets extremely
complicated but he he proposes that
everything emerges through this cue to
signal transition well this is probably
a scene where the lion is feasting on
the gazelle and then the camera backs
out and then you cue the PBS announcer
to go and so these endless struggle for
survival goes on and on and to the right
and and then the credits roll and you
know oh but but yeah I don't I don't
think we really even know how many
signals are going on absolutely we don't
it's just it's it's it's mind-boggling
you know as a as a person who straddles
the me because I I do business
consulting I feel like I i straddle the
border between technology and biology
because
is a business is a niche construction
adaptation of you know how people get
fed right a business is a living
organism okay it's just it's just a
population of right and then but they're
also interacting with all this
technology and they have computers and
they have cell phones and and everything
and it's all Co evolving right and you
get like one little technological
advantage and then all of a sudden the
company grows 800 percent and I I just
see all these things that's being very
parallel personally I think and there's
so much to be learned from biology it's
it's just it's beyond my comprehension
it's it's amazing signaling Theory
actually that Stewart West use I believe
it a I don't know if it started in
business or if it started in biology but
it's used in both I mean is you're a
corporation is signaling to investors in
all sorts of different ways and knowing
how that works once once you know that
you can you can manipulate your
investors which lots of business people
are trying to study what what signals
investors are picking up on so they can
manipulate them it's uh it's an arms
race that's right in that way and you
know I'll just mention one other thing I
met this lady who was heavily involved
in epigenetics research and she made
this kind of she said you know when we
were sequencing genomes we thought that
was a lot of data she goes now that
we're sequencing epigenetics
she's like gigabytes upon gigabytes upon
gigabytes it's like exponentially more
information because I could have
different epigenetics going on in the
palms of my hands and I have going on in
my time or right so it gets really
complicated but at the end of the day
it's still signals it's encode or
message decoder if you can understand
that you're you're off to a good start
that the thing I want to drive home is
the genetic code really is a code it's
not like a code it is literally a code
and people studying the origin of the
genetic code understand this I see a lot
of creationists using the existence of
the of the
code as an argument for the existence of
God I think that's horribly flawed you
and I should probably do a debate about
that sometime or yeah depending on if
our if our audience would appreciate
that
anyway well I'll I'll just add that that
you know 10 10 years ago I used this as
a as a out-and-out God of the gaps
argument and I I grew uncomfortable with
that
I don't like God of the gaps arguments I
think that you know there's there's five
five explanations for where did the
genetic code come from humans invented
it aliens did it happened randomly and
accidentally it it's an undiscovered
processor a lot of physics or God did it
and and I I think number four
undiscovered process or law of physics
that's that's where you need to go with
it I don't think the aliens explanation
is particularly helpful I don't think
the humans time-traveled explanation is
helpful I certainly don't think that it
had happened randomly and accidentally
explanation I don't think that's even
science I would love it if somebody
figured out a law of physics or an
emergent process that makes codes I
think it would be a huge breakthrough
and again you know we're we're lobbying
for that with our prize money so but
it's definitely a code there's no
question about that where we are the
closest in discovering the natural
process for this is in the RNA world
hypothesis and that you're getting the
evolution of strands of RNA without a
code necessary but there are lots of
problems with that still and I I would I
would put my money on that that's where
we end up finding a solution to all this
is through the it's through not
necessarily RNA world hypothesis in a
strict sense but through replicating
polymers developing a communication
system in the same way that these the
lion and Gizella
have developed a communication system
any evolving entities could develop a
communications
and I think that that's the origin of
the genetic code it's is somewhere in
there
and trying to pinpoint exactly that
process is gonna be extremely difficult
but I think that we can discover the
principles and hopefully I eventually
observe a similar communication system
developing in the laboratory that would
that would be the ideal it's not
happened yet that would be the ideal
well may the best man win
I mean I'm all for I'm all for somebody
figuring this out I think I think it's a
really pivotal discovery I don't think
it's trivial all it would be a big deal
well Perry thank you it was great fun
conversation thank you for having me on
it's a it's a pleasure you have a pretty
loyal following and it's nice to you
know be trusted with your with your
peeps I'll have a link to your book
which I didn't like
in the video description and a link to
my my review of it one more thing I'd
like to point out to my audience about
this conversation is if you found any of
this useful
just to point out that there's this
tendency in our culture right now I
don't know if it's like inspired by
Donald Trump or what it is but do you
completely dismiss someone because they
don't share some of your views but I'm
sure everyone who listened to this got
some good information from Perry Perry
Marshall disagrees with me on some
things that both of us think are very
important but in spite of that we can
still have good conversations and learn
from each other
and see each other as experts on
specific topics and that is extremely
important thing to be able to do yes and
not in this world and it seems like
people are not being able to do this as
much lately you know I I really want to
say there there are all kinds of people
in biology and everywhere else that I
vehement ly disagree with but I have
learned very important things from most
of them okay like not even a tiny
fraction like their in fact I don't
think there's anything more valuable
than wading into some multiple groups of
people that you have significant
disagreements with and go first of all
are they writing at my run like
seriously could I just be completely
wrong about this that's the starting
point but also you know what can i
gleaned what's good and you know most
people have positive intention they're
trying to figure stuff out a lot of
times there's they're nervous about
things so yeah little little tolerance
and in grace goes a long way
Thank You Perry this is great thank you
John